>>> HELLO.
AYN ASH IN WASHINGTON
WHTHATE OF UNION ISI
AAT LEAST 20 CIVILIAN
MEN SHOT ETYT
NEARBY TOWNS INTSED A SIMILARSS
"POSTAPOCALYPTICICDER CUINS THLI
TE CONTRO
THE PONTA UKRAINIAN FIAL T
WILL FACE F
N UKRAINE'S EA
RE AND THI
POT IN
EAST, TH MISSILED DE
STRIKES WILL LIKEL
JOINING ME N SECRE
ONY BLINKEN.
T WITH THEORC IMAGES YOUR REACT
SEE EVIDENCE OF CRIMES AGAINST U
A
THE GUT,ND.'VE IA'S GRESSIHA
THAT RUS F R CRIMKINGD  ATROCIT
TOAT, TO PROVIDE THEION THE HAVL
OF THIS GEAND THERE  BE ACCOUNT.
ORMALI ITH
GOING ON EVERY
LONG AS RUSSIA'S NST AND
WHY ITO AN END. KRNIMINISTER SAA
UKRAINIANS A
BEYOND WARS, DO E
THISS ?
EVERYTHING WE SEE, PUTT
MAKE SURE THNS AND ORGANIZATIONS
LOOKING  IE DEPARTMENT, HAVE
EVERYTHING THEY NEEDO ASSESS
OOK PL
WHO'S RESPONSIBLE ANAT IT
NTTO.
>> TALK ABOUT PUNISHMENT HERE.
EUL IMPOSEEWR
SA THIS.
AHEMPOSE MORE
SANC EXALE IACKING DOWNN
N BA IN
BANKI SYSTEM?
>>ANA, IT EVERY
SINGLE DAYTIGHTENING AND ADDINW
PARTNE ARLD.HE, THE  REELING.ER
THE MAJOERS THAT ITSLLT BY 10%
MAJOR COMPANY FROM RUSMP, GROWI.
OVERTERM, THE RT
CONTROLS IMPOSED MEANS TN'T HAVT
NOW ANING FORWARD ASG ASD FUTURI
JUST AOUE DA A HAVE A LIFEINE WR
SOMETHING G ALONG WITH WESTERN
>> IN CONSNTRSATION WITHND PAR
EEC TIGHTEN
AND STRE
ON MAKING  ETHE ENERGY I
NETOAR
ANR WHICH ITASBUT NEXT YEAR ASEL
ALREADY ATEGIC AND LOOK ATHIS.
SETBACK FOSS A
DEFEAT.
THREMS.
WAUKRAINS
SOVEREIGNTY AND SECONDSERTIAN W
LOST.
E PEY ER THAON
THREALLY AE ASK YOU T  MILNSA
RN PART OF UKR
ZEACTUALLY
SAID TT BAKYIVOWYOU SAIDT TH DO,
T
>> W THAT.EL
IT'S TOO EO SAT
ACTUALLYEABECAUSE THEY
AND
RESTOCKING, ANREPLEN
TKYIV.SO VERSSE
SEEING IS WHAT IT SEEMS TO BE.
THAT'S WHAT THAT UVE DANA,THEREI
ALREMO
THEY'RE
SINGLE
TORY THETROLIN
BECAUSE T
THEY WILL NOT BEJEED
RUSSIAN OCCUPATIAS
E U D WITHY ITS SO
URGENT THAT RUSSIA AND THIS SSDI
STTHAINE'S H T
NEGOTIATING TABLAND HOPEFULLY
ING THIS TO A QUICKER  ARE REPOE
UKRAINE'SAN TELL ME
AB ROL
FACILITATING THAT?
>> I CAN'T GET INTO SPECIFIC S S
ADMIRA $N IN
$1.6 BILONCLG MANY DRE O UKRAIN.
GIVEOUAMPLE.TWEEN THE ALLIES ANK
E'REING TO
MAKE SIANS HAVE THE S NEED
THEYAN CD EN D FFBECA AND
OUSODS HE U.S
TAS IN?
MOTHNTRIESE
P DEAL WITH ONERN ONS PROVIDSE
WOULD THE U.S.IDE  G SO , T,
IS U
WH THEY GOTIATE SOMETHING THATTS
THEIR NEEDS,VENTY
FIRST OFEMOST IT'S U  SS UKRAIN
THEM ANDHE PRESIDENTZELENSKYY.
WHEN IT COMES TO THE E EVERYTHIS
T DETER FURTHE
AND WILL LOOK AT ANYTHING WE CAN
UP TH OUOUNDS LI T
MIGHME INTO MINGROM IA>>ETTING N
P UKRA FEEBUT WEWANT TO WHAT W
ITSELF GOING FORWARD, TO FUTURE
>> BEFORE T YOGOE
STRATIONNNOUNCEDTH
TRUMP-ERA RE
RESTEN
THN  COMESNISTRATI S
THSCY? IT CO THE ABOUT.ERRL IST
THOW HAPPENING, THENY
AND THE VICE PRE'S FOCUS
ASL.
G SURE
THAT PPLE ROUR
OPHOME GOI FED
CHCEF LEAVINEVCOME TO THE UNITEE
OFD
AI OUR FOCUS. ON
MAKI SUR